hello and welcome to this video playing
kill the yarn here with white I don't
quite remember what what to set up is
playing against this ig6 mmmm it doesn't
he go for some a fire stuff nobody takes
here okay
yeah it's very flexible set up here for
both sides and many possible ideas I'm
just trying to do something with my two
bishops long-term you three is stopping
efore III this pushing the pawn all the
way through I definitely need some water
I'm currently having a plus one scoring
and securely on is one of the big duels
yeah I've got 40 games against them I
think I got the most games against the
adverb it'd probably kill the on the
second second this is international was
a card or demora from italy by the way
so what's the deal what's the deal is
there some tech tech going on like takes
Knight takes or something crazy let me
think about this for just one second
maybe I should do this first wait takes
Knight takes bishop 2g 792 we should see
three now that's good for whites up ok
night see for now right this should be
them should be the move angling for the
night coming to d6 so we probably will
switch it to the Kings side somewhere
Queen to g5 maybe on what you see up to
2 f5 at the f5 this is 96 stuff probably
not immediately but it's something that
he has to attend to quickly there were a
lot sure where he wants to go doesn't
feel very comfortable
also quite a head on the clock that's
nice yeah here I was thinking we should
be too could be an idea putting him into
this I mean I don't see him men coming
with the key queen to age three all that
quickly maybe creature is six but then I
thought 96 for Bishop c4 I mean maybe he
sacrifices stuff but I don't don't
believe it 96 is kind of annoying here
yeah okay if he sacrifices exchange or
the power to him Queen age 3m that's
it's possible I thought Bishop c4 would
be a problem but maybe it isn't actually
a then then then then the Queen goes to
age three and absolutely ah ok so that
that didn't turn out all that well I can
go here though this could be interesting
maybe he goes it was 95 or something
anyway tweenage three I should prevent
yeah 95 mm of course yeah absolutely
mmm i don't know i don't have anything
cool here takes Bishop c4 witnesses this
is not doing this is not all that grade
Queen to e5 looks wrong and okay don't
want to spend even more time here yes
unfortunately unfortunately as 93 m now
maybe hook something hook somewhere bit
of an issue now that it didn't it didn't
turn out all to all to grade seems he
did a good job Ian oh I did a bad job
it's often kind of happening at the same
time okay so b5 and I'd be too I guess
you noticed I just want to get rid of
this night down let's do it
good news is news not it's all the news
but the time situation is good it
doesn't have a look to the C file at the
moment and if he moves the night and
might just have / should be five I think
I have that I mean he's okay here of
course he can take on be two or
something okay and soon takes cheeks I
can just take like everything now
hmm just a second here is there
something threatening immediately and I
can think then it sounds a bit a bit of
an annoyance really it should takes
gphone cream shakes 93 takes rook takes
bishop jakes and so complete trade I'm
kind of scared if I don't do that that
I'm getting into trouble this is
absolutely nothing but grass salad yeah
yeah I think I'm taking this run around
it's just nothing I mean I'm back and do
the stupid hacking for the time but what
did i do it did something crazy and that
was weird I have to open this up again
so I was tough I mean at one point it
should have been nice but I couldn't
quite get it to work so I took it he
took it I just night takes you four
winds porn okay that's true sometimes
it's not all that difficult it's just
windsor flat on ok and it's look nice
though this this is this and now what's
the thing here understand the engine
wants to take v7 this this is merciless
you know the thing is I thought about
the movement I was scared yeah and the
engine just test place this move
this move to play here this this this
I'm still scared but ok it's not going
to be a main somebody is still kind of
feeling like EA egos his casino f3 un
hmm yeah okay this was probably too
cautious and now I think some things are
good for for him of course this you
should before I'm just barely okay here
probably be five yeah 94 immediately
it's given by the engine that's somewhat
better for black but seemed check read
sets not easy to play
no that's not at all easy to play it's
certainly better than yeah here here I'm
okay and I'm not surprised that the
engine finds something better than the
tea than the capture here but I just I
got scared the engine wants to do this
and I don't quite get why this is better
can you not just stuck take everything
takes tags so why doesn't roop takes
work luke t 1 is good ok I b5 is hanging
ok mmhmm yeah this is the kind of move
that I think not easy to see if you if
you really don't have time to check it
out so you kind of scared about the
check but that actually is the wrong
move and this this ok I'm just
double-checking a keg and I didn't see
that so I went for them for the total
exchange check t IM back and it's just
nothing going on and i really feel it's
kind of stupid to play this kind of
thing on time and there's simply nothing
going on ok well thanks for watching